who's Ryan don't bring anyone love into
this
[Music]
in fact Tom and I had a conversation on
a plane that I said to my house
Christine handle this because I have
friends like Joe Rogan that they give a
fuck about the Mars and so I was always
real interested in Kristina's
transformation yeah I was very
interested well she got pregnant how she
was gonna react to it and you said to me
don't ever become a woman
Christine don't ever become a woman
finger places Christine pass the
potatoes devil they're going Christine
how you doing we were shooting the
student film Christine yeah 15 years ago
who the fuck knows well I have to take
my dick out in front of Christine and
whacked off no but will Christine wait
to see if I ejaculated no Christine were
the left who sits around and waits for
come to come all over your stomach if we
sit there oh
Christina will kick me in the stomach
and ran out of there yeah I know this
for a fact yeah Christina hold on let's
discuss calmly I really like your
podcast so there's a duck duck Christine
it's all pieces of the cow and the pig
not you the hearts the eyeballs listen
if I'm fucked up you guys good pussy and
I bet yogurt he's 69 you need your ass
from behind and it's got a Wang to it
you think I'm gonna tap in go Christine
now you got one either with that way
[Music]